eq allen or avocat bonsoir énorme merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
l'ex policier donc un des règles chauvin
qui comparaît devant la justice pour la
première fois que doit-on attendre de ce
procès on imagina à haut risque très
symbolique aux états unis qui peut même
peut-être changer les choses dans un
sens comme dans l'autre
effectivement on pourrait changer les
choses au niveau du système judiciaire
en matière d'immunité de la police mais
l'impact social aguerris se case
s'applique déjà les yeux beaucoup de
changements dans les conversations
autour de la brutalité policière et elle
autour de la vie des noirs aux états
unis on a pu voir qu'à à minneapolis
il change la façon de maintenir l'ordre
on sait on dit souvent que la police est
intouchable aux états unis très soutenue
notamment par par les syndicats est ce
qu'il y aura vraiment selon vous un
tournant désormais après cette affaire
un changement dans les états d'esprit il
ya un très large mouvement de réduction
des financements de la police le conseil
municipal de minneapolis a voté hier
afin de démanteler la police a donc
effectivement c'est déjà du changement
et vous l'avez vu dans les rues les
conversations on change les démocrates
ce matin ont proposé un projet de loi
qui pourrait ne pas réussir mais qui
traite ce sujet alors effectivement la
ville de minneapolis qui annonce vouloir
je suis démanteler sa police car elle
n'est pas réformable c'est une première
vous vous attendiez à une telle décision
qu'elles vont en être les conséquences
avec de crainte que les conséquences
pourraient être très positive nous
vivons dans une société où la police
peut parfois créer du danger
des crimes en plus car ce marteau peut
s'abattre sur beaucoup de personnes donc
plutôt que la police pour avoir besoin
par exemple de travailleurs sociaux
d'autres moyens de gérer les problèmes
par exemple dans la sphère de georges
flotte il s'agissait d'un faux billets
et eu beaucoup de vandalisme de deux
incendies et de troubles civique pour
c'est ce billet ce faux billets cela
pourrait aurait pu être géré très
différemment alors vous dites oui on
peut trouver une alternative à la police
effectivement elle va être démantelée
aujourd'hui comment on pourrait évoluer
les choses une autre police autrement
vous nous dites
effectivement il s'agirait d'un système
social différent souvent dans les écoles
par exemple les écoles privées ou dans
certains s'attendent quartier on trouve
d'autres façons de les gérer les
situations et par exemple il sein de
larges famille on a un père une mère qui
qui font respecter l ap dans la sphère
lui mais il ya d'autres façons de de
sanctionner les enfants que dell de les
punir
c'est la même chose avec la police on
pourrait retrouver à des personnes qui
peuvent contrôler la communité sans
arrêter les gens l'arrestation
c'est au centre du système policier et
aux états unis
on a plus de prisonniers que tout autre
pays du monde et plus de personnes de
couleur donc cela ne peut plus exister
emprisonné quelqu'un ne résout pas les
problèmes sociaux au sein de notre
société et ne résout pas les problèmes
d'inégalité car la plupart des
prisonniers sont des noirs alors qu'ils
représentent moins de 20% du total de la
population américaine
en france il ya soit un débat sur ce
qu'on appelle la police de proximité une
police qui est voilà sur le terrain au
contact
notamment la population avec parfois
justement ça se passe mal est-ce qu'il
est souhaitable justement qui est cette
police selon une police qui est au
contact même de la population c'est
l'une des deux l'un de ses projets de
loi démocrate que la police soit une
police de proximité est effectivement
plus la pluie ses proches de la
communauté - on a deux problèmes parce
que la personne arrêtée est familière
aux policiers et il ya des problèmes
grâce à cette connaissance
si on est allé à l'école avec le
personnes du voisinage
il les connaît mieux et on est plus à
même de calmer les situations ce n'est
pas le cas aux états unis
il n'y a pas de points communs entre la
police et la population il n'y a pas de
communauté merci beaucoup alors avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors que l'ex-policier derek chauvin
comparaît devant la justice pour la
première fois devant la justice
évidemment du minnesota merci à vous